welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston let's go back and break down
Marvel's Loki season 1 episode 2 the
variant ahead of Loki season 2 we are
doing this Loki season one re-watch and
we were able to find even more details
in Easter eggs so let's check this out
with a fresh perspective because nothing
matters nothing has any consequence you
should dance while you still can alright
we open hearing some renaissance music
playing but you know what it's a fake
out because this ain't Elizabeth in
England it's just a written fair in
Oshkosh Wisconsin 1985 an important year
because this really is a Nexus year in
our reality it's when Back to the Future
released and historically that really
was a huge movement in pop culture that
people started thinking about time
travel constantly because that movie was
so popular even though it wasn't the
first time travel story ever told I know
I know HD Wells existed but Back to the
Future was a moment it mattered to most
Americans at least also in the comics
Oshkosh is home to window Von AKA Quasar
and that series was written by who Mark
grinwald and Mobius and mobius's comic
likeness was based on Mark grinwald's
appearance Hunter see he shows up with
some Minutemen and they're immediately
called out by this woman played by
comedian Kate Birdland what's going on
you guys are dressed right
who must need this you know and I really
love how they use so many comedians on
this show it really drives home the fact
that everything the TVA is doing is all
a far is designed by he remains and he's
just laughing at all of us he's using
these comedic actors because he wants
the funniest looking and sounding
puppets everything about this is meant
to disorient a Renaissance Fair is
conceptually one time period
masquerading as another a big cosplay a
big fake so it just makes it more
difficult for these time cops to spot
anachronistic items and they're further
disoriented when they track the Loki
variant to this green tint with a golden
sign out front Loki's signature colors
and the audio recording intro for the
ren Fair show starts playing loudly
which when you think about it must have
been pre-recorded by Sylvie meaning
she's in GarageBand putting this
together anyway a lot of preparation
went into this
[Music]
yes hero Bonnie Tyler's 1984 hit the
song was recorded for the movie
Footloose which is Peter Quill's
favorite movie but also this narration
foreshadows the events ahead for Loki
and Sylvie will evil Prevail or are we
Holding Out for a Hero either or
phrasing it this way just makes it sound
like evil will prevail if a hero shows
up and the most active protagonist in
these six episodes is Sylvie and she
does make a decision that brings danger
to the Multiverse Sylvie pairs her
Consciousness with C20 by touching her
temple with green magic the way she does
this looks similar to Wanda performing
her illusion curse on The Avengers in
Age of Ultron but here the spell is mind
control something iron Loki could only
do with a scepter containing the Mind
Stone so this sets up what we later
learned from Mobius that Loki variants
can have different powers the song
lyrics of where have all the good men
gone and where are all the gods just a
little hint that this God is a woman and
also perhaps the hero these Minutemen
need to free them from their illusion of
Life the TBA and in fact we see Sylvie
in c20's memories in a future episode so
Zoe picks up the temp pad and its
display has options for time door Miss
minutes settings and directory so miss
minutes is selectable as an option which
means that she could show up whenever
and wherever they want or maybe by
tapping this this is how you release
surgical full Kaiju as last resort like
we see in the Loki season 2 trailer so
back in the TDA Loki reads wake that's
mobius's jet ski magazine that we saw in
the end credits of last episode season 2
will show mobius's origin in Cleveland
Ohio in 2022 is a jet ski salesman Loki
asks Miss minutes are you recording or
are you alive uh sort of both and then
he starts to swatter and then tries to
like hit her with the magazine and she
hops around if you listen closely her
shoes are making noises as she connects
with these surfaces
again I explored what Miss minutes is in
a recent video she's not just a hologram
I believe she is sentient temporal
radiation and I'm sorry for all the past
times I already said temporal I just
love shrimp tempura but from here
forward I'm going to say it correctly
temporal temporal temporal temporal I'm
sorry but I think my favorite Easter egg
in all of Loki is that there is a
multiple choice question on his computer
screen Thanos has two apples to eat both
but realizes he wants more he goes back
in time 20 minutes and eats the apples
again does this mean that apples will
not have existed in the timeline he left
hey no because time is constantly
happening B the question doesn't matter
because the branch cannot change another
time Branch see Thanos would have been
hungry prior because the grandfather
Paradox already accounted for the change
in matter before its move so all three
options reflect explanations of time
travel we've heard in movies before B is
currently selected on this screen which
would align with Moby's logic about
timelines being unaffected by what
happens in other branches when Thanos
goes back in time to eat apples again
he's created a new Branch timeline Etc
however episode 6 of this series will
prove that all of the above are actually
correct for Kang time is constantly
happening and thanos's hunger and his
eating of apples aren't linked by cause
and effect like the drawer full of
Infinity Stones there are countless
apples for him to eat in infinite
permutations so that's really why it's
no but answer C the grandfather Paradox
suggests that Thanos is hunger after
eating two apples was a result of
reality erasing the Apple matter from
his stomach to justify his need to go
back in time to eat them in the past
making a closed loop which despite all
the talk of Branch timelines in this
series and in Avengers end game that is
actually how Kang sees it it's a
predestined Loop where even the act of
time travel is part of the pre-ordained
script but all of these are presented as
a choice which is weird all of the above
is not an option here making this test a
trick like Loki's living captcha test in
episode one this is really a void comp
test to measure how indoctrinated Loki
is becoming into the TVA Orthodoxy yes
I'm obsessed with this multiple choice
question and actually I interviewed a
member of the VFX team who wrote out the
script and got specific notes from the
producers of the Loki series on which
words to change go watch them that video
because it's fascinating how these
Easter eggs actually come into existence
I've talked about this too long but I
will leave you with this this reference
to the apples when we first meet he
remains the finale what is he eating an
apple in Loki season two what is
mobius's favorite type of pie from
McDonald's even more than the key lime
pie he eats in the TV automatic apple
pie I'm telling you apples extremely
important
Doctor Strange in 26
expression and time reversion Works was
an apple okay we see some more of Loki's
variants the TVA is pruned a lot of
these guys almost more than any other
variant we could see a blue Frost giant
version of Loki labeled l1247 but that's
just on the wide shot and close-up it's
l6792 there's a cyclist Loki who just
won the Tour de France that and close-up
is l1247 l6792 and close-up is a big
beastly Loki that looks like it's
straight out of the pages of a d d
handbook l8914 has a big beard and big
black horns that look a lot more
goat-like and then an armored Warrior
Loki l7803 Moby says that each Loki can
have different powers and Loki clarifies
the difference between illusion
projection and duplication casting
illusion projection depicts a detailed
image from outside oneself which is
perceptible in the outside world like
when Loki projected the form of Steve
Rogers over himself duplication casting
involves recreating an exact facsimile
of the body as it is in its current
state being a true holographic mirror of
its molecular structure so that would be
anytime Loki tricks people like Thor
with a double of himself or or when he
did this to all those Germans in the
2012 Adventures so at the crime scene at
the ren Fair Loki delivers a monologue
we have a saying in Asgard whatever
Wolf's ears Wolf's teeth and ear he's
alluding to Wolf references as a not to
fenrir or Fenris and Marvel that's the
wolf figure that Loki is often
associated with in mythology but as we
learned in episode 3 Loki's connections
with North's culture do have an
authentic form of music because for Loki
it is just impossible to sing
inauthentically this is kind of a Rick
and Morty thing where there's a younger
form of Rick that anytime he sings
that's the only way he can express his
true self and obviously a lot of the
writers on this show including Mike
Waldron wrote on Rick and Morty before
this now on the Chrono monitor screen
back in the TBA we see the branch being
pruned and other past branch locations
tick past including nidivalir that's the
Armory realm and infinity War where itri
helped Thor Forge Stormbreaker and sakar
of course the trash planet that we saw
in Thor Ragnarok the timekeeper statues
in rensselaer's office have the same
kitsugi cracked pattern that he remains
Citadel has suggesting that Rensselaer
may have been that fourth timekeeper
statue that was broken in the lobby
either way there is a connection between
Brent Slayer and he remains King
throughout this seeming hear this
haunting theremin music a song that was
actually composed by Tchaikovsky and
performed in this case by Clara rockmore
the statues of these three timekeepers
once again watch over Rensselaer just
like they do in the courtroom and again
the timekeeper of AST is the one that
stands directly behind her when she's at
her desks arms are outstretched where
zorth and vanth hold our glasses there's
also this cool hourglass pattern on the
black doors leading into the office
Mobius notices the San Diego snow globe
where'd you get that one the snow globe
I love those I don't remember bringing
back that case Brent Slayer shrugs this
off saying Mobius isn't the only analyst
working for her but between that him not
remembering that he left ring stains on
the side table and not remembering the
penny uses from Franklin D Roosevelt
High School she's clear the TDA is
messing with his memories and
controlling them in episode 6 we realize
that Rensselaer has his pin because it's
where she used to work before she was
brought to the TVA and we actually see a
bunch of these pens on her desk Mobius
whistles for Loki to follow him like a
dog and then they bicker as they walk
through these identical hallways it's
clear they use the same set over again
when they Round the Corner totally
parallels what we see in Severance this
is just kind of a symbolic workplace
Labyrinth that any white collar worker
just has to go through every morning as
they trudge to their cubicle Mobius says
because I see a scared little boy
shivering in the cold and you kind of
feel bad for that ice runt which I love
this line because as a frost giant Loki
shouldn't be affected by cold but he was
really raised by the asgardians so he's
always felt like an outsider this
elevator ride into the depths of the
archives of the TVA very trippy he's
actually shot in the Atlanta Marriott
Marquis Hotel who's dressed up with his
timekeeper statues and TVA archived
bookshelves the number 372 appears
behind Loki could be a nod to the mighty
thorious shoe number 372 which featured
an appearance of the TVA Loki goes
through a report of Sylvie's destruction
of a central California Oriole field
this is a different oil field than the
one she destroyed in Oklahoma in episode
one but again she took the reset charges
there Sylvia is actually listed in the
file as Sylvie lafi daughter meaning
daughter of Laffy like laughing son but
look he's so annoyed by what he sees as
just a busy work task that he doesn't
register this important info yet at the
reference desk a librarian is listening
to box orchestral suite number three in
D Major
which is actually a really cool Easter
egg it's a nod to the movie Seven when
detectives Mills and Somerset are in the
library looking for info on their killer
[Music]
Loki director Kate Herron actually
called out this moment at a panel when
she was asked about influences for the
show she said quote stylistically I
would say me and DB Autumn Gerald were
really inspired by a lot of more films
and he could see that in our lighting
and how we approached it seven is a very
heavy influence there's a little
reference to seven episode two a little
needle drop which I'm sure fans of that
film will recognize instantly now the
floors behind Loki are labeled syf lk3
and 2w1 they correspond to the floor as
we saw in the elevator and actually
Mobius Taps this button again in the
latest trailer for Loki season 2. so I
guess they're gonna go back to that part
of the archives the librarian tells Loki
that all files pertaining the creation
of the TBA at the beginning of time and
the end of time are classified the
origin questions hopefully will get
answered with Victor timely in 1893 in
season two Loki reads a report on the
destruction of Asgard as seen in Thor
Ragnarok it's listed as a Class 7
apocalypse total planetary destruction
and he sheds a tear as he reads
casualties
9719. remember this Loki isn't the Loki
lived through the Ragnarok event so he's
feeling this all for the first time and
we see the words codename Revengers
which is a team named Thor proposed to
Valkyrie in that movie Loki sees that
there was Zero variance energy detected
which gives them the idea that Sylvia is
hiding out in historical apocalyptic
timeline events he rushes tell Mobius
about the sun's destroying Moby's salad
in the process and stealing Casey's Boku
fruit juice which is another
discontinued drink from the 90s like the
Justice soda it's my undeniable right as
a man of the 90s to quench my thirst in
my own way I want a Boku look he says
that he could go right before an
apocalyptic event and do whatever the
TVA won't detect it because everything
gets wiped and he uses the example of
pushing Hulk off the Rainbow Bridge
which actually happens in Ragnarok
though he doesn't know it when Hulk
fights that wolf Fenris Loki wants to
test this Theory but Mobius theories
will stab him in the back okay after
studied almost every moment of your
entire life you've literally stabbed
people in the back like 50 times we saw
one of those times when Loki killed poor
Coulson and Avengers 2012 R.I.P Colson
or maybe the lmd is still alive if
Agents of Shield will just be confirmed
as Canon this video is sponsored by
Helix sleep their Labor Day Sale is
running now and it's a great time to
update your mattress you can get 25 off
your purchase for a limited time check
out the Helix site for more details I'm
not going to pretend this is the first
time you've heard me say that and with
good reason I've been sleeping on a
helix mattress for two years now and
it's great it's the best mattress I've
ever owned finding the perfect mattress
can be difficult but helix's sleep quiz
makes it so easy you just take the quiz
and Helix finds the perfect mattress for
you I wanted a medium firm mattress with
lumbar support that sleeps cool and I
got matched with a dusk Luxe Helix
mattress and get this there is no
fiberglass in Helix mattresses so you
won't lose any sleep over what you're
sleeping on Helix delivers your mattress
right to your door with free shipping in
the US the mattress comes rolled up in a
box and it's super easy to set up
yourself Helix has a 100 night sleep
trial so you get more than three months
to make sure you love your mattress
Helix mattresses have a 10 year warranty
Helix even offers financing options and
flexible payment plans so a great
night's sleep is never far away I love
my Helix mattress I think you would too
so if you're looking for a new bed check
out Helix sleep their Labor Day Sale is
running now it's a perfect time to
upgrade your sleep with 25 off a helix
mattress plus two free pillows click the
link below or go to helixsleep.com
rockstars to find out more about this
limited time offer they visit Pompeii in
79 A.D moments before the eruption of
Mount Vesuvius Loki's theory is proven
correct when he raises a Ruckus by
releasing his fellow horned friends some
goats and tells everyone that he's from
the future which produces no variance
energy no Branch timeline back in the
TVA Mobius explains his fascination with
jet skis in the early 1990s for a brief
Shining Moment there was a beautiful
Union
Form and Function which we call the jet
ski even though that scene of Mobius
selling jet skis in season 2 is
reportedly in 2022 Mobius is a guy still
stuck in the past he's thinking about
the 90s he's a nostalgic and there's
some symbolism in his love for jet skis
as they travel on no painted lane or
path they're largely unregulated and
pretty accessible to anyone compared to
motorcycles or airplanes they really are
the vehicle of Freedom movies remembers
the bluey gum from episode one that
Sylvie left behind on one of her crime
scenes and uses that to narrow down the
time that she is hiding in since it was
only sold on Earth between
2047-2051 and Loki searches through
possible apocalyptic disasters during
that narrow four-year window it's not
the climate disaster 2048
or the tsunami of 2051. let's go let's
go 2050 the extinction of the swallow is
that a thing completely screwed up the
ecosystem Krakatoa erupted in 2049 as
well no cabling that's a lot of boom
booms Krakatoa remember is the
Indonesian volcano that erupted in 1883
and covered half the world in Ash so
here remains has definitely scheduled a
lot of apocalyptic events for the future
and I've always wondered if it's because
he knew there existed one timeline where
Earth was destroyed by tiamat's
emergence so Loki zeroes in on the Rocks
cart disaster when a category 8
Hurricane hits Haven Hills Alabama in
2050. now our current hurricane
classification system only goes up to
category five so this means at some
point in the future meteorologists have
to adjust to keep up with the increasing
disaster power in this report you can
see that the entire town was annihilated
10 835 people so rockskart would be a
subsidiary of Roxanne the recurring MCU
energy conglomerate so at some point
like many evil companies they just take
over all of retail we get this amazingly
timed One-Shot sequence where Mobius
gives Loki back his daggers which are
immediately snatched back by Hunter b-15
Melanie you actually help us catch this
variant and who knows best friend well
good enough for a face-to-face for the
timekeepers and say that one step at a
time
absolutely not now how did they time out
the block into this we can actually see
the moment Tom Hiddleston signals when
we masaku to enter by raising his voice
on the words time Keepers the face for
the time keepers
I say that one step at a time
just in case
absolutely not by hearing the words time
Keepers that's how one mean knows when
to enter to perfectly time that grab and
then we cut from this constantly
rotating shot of Hunter B15 outlining
the mission to the Rocks card billboard
of an idyllic Paradise kind of left it
back to the future lion Estates
billboard that in the 1985 timeline this
interest just covered in graffiti but
here in the billboard they leave in the
Roxanne smokestacks spouting pollution
into the air surrounding this beautiful
beach City not carried one bit about the
Optics and then with the billboard being
destroyed we see the Direct effects of
that pollution this climate disaster
destroying the billboard and the entire
town behind it some fossil fuel powered
buildings completely explode silliness
that even in 2050 there is still
powering all these buildings with gas
lines meaning that fire is causing just
as much damage alongside the wind the
rain and the flooding as a Florida kid I
can tell you while flood water is
definitely the most destructive part of
a hurricane structural fires are no joke
either they're a big thing from gas
lines being damaged pilot lights going
and out appliances just being left on by
mistake when the power is otherwise out
no one being home to catch the fires
before they can spread yeah fires are
really bad too we see a hologram of a
happy roxon employee glitching she has
caught in her own Loop just like all of
these characters are there are two buses
parked out front this is a destination
for all these people they're brought
here as a safe space to ride out the
storm they thought they'd be safe Mobius
makes Loki walk in front of him so there
would be no way Loki could stab him in
the back just like he was worried about
earlier once they're inside Loki uses
magic to try his clothes clearly
relishing the fact that he's now outside
the TBA he can perform his old tricks
again but this also signals to the
viewer that sorcery in this place is
possible letting us know that Sylvie's
especially dangerous and that her
sorcery may already be in effect Hunter
B15 says Loki needs to stay with her
during the mission pointed to the
hierarchy of the TVA and reminding us of
that hunters and analysts work in a
tandem poster from episode one Sylvie
watches them from the security cameras
and the screen in the upper right shows
the helper robot still rolling Loki and
B15 come upon this guy who says that
he's buying azaleas right now because
this is a hurricane sale a hurricane
sale that's how often it happens like
Rock's card is now playing into it but
really this guy is possessed by Sylvie's
Consciousness and when B15 touches him
she transfers into her just like Loki
did at the start of the episode Sylvia
is really all doing this monologuing to
Loki to stall for time they're more
alike than they are different Mobius
finds Hunter C20 in the store's break
room which has a poster that reads a
great place to work a great place to
shop everything you need for happiness
yeah corporate propaganda it is
everywhere C20 just keeps repeating it's
real it's real it's real and I want to
go home sounded very much like Dorothy
in The Wizard of Oz convincing herself
that there's no place like home she
apparently gave up where the timekeepers
are so Sylvie is finally in a position
to carry out her plan to bomb the sacred
timeline and take these three out Sylvie
transfers her Consciousness to the
employee Randy and Loki looks down at
B15 he's worried about her they've
really come a long way and I love how
Randy has this electronic name badge
that still says welcome can I help you
it's a cool world detail because it
shows how Roxanne just uses their
employees as walking advertisements for
discounts and sales they found yet
another way to make money into your time
50. B15 wakes up in a similar shell
shock State as C20 and then still be
transfers her Consciousness from Randy
to this big boy trucker looking dude
Loki gets tossed around landing on the
ground in that same position he didn't
throw Ragnarok I have been falling
for 30 minutes but as trucker Sylvie
punches that TV behind Loki you can
actually see another really cool detail
from this episode the TV reads storm of
the Millennium and it actually lists the
storm as a category nine meaning was a
category nine before it made landfall
became a category eight it was even
worse than we thought and look closely
at that storm path it was really two
storms converging a perfect storm which
I think parallels symbolically these two
Loki variants has two separate deadly
storms combining together into the
perfect storm of Chaos in an otherwise
orderly timeline all of this is an
elaborate dance between two Star-Crossed
variants and Sylvie presents herself
here setting the record straight and
taking some wind out of Loki's Sails
this isn't about you yes it isn't all
about just one Loki it's about both of
them working together in an Echoes what
the Ancient One Told Doctor Strange as
he began to understand the concept of
the Multiverse
now Sylvia ends this episode by blowing
up the secret timeline dropping these
stolen reset charges throughout history
creating chaos and a bunch of branches
rensslayer's screen shows a bunch of
historical dates and important locations
what's interesting is we never really
see the consequences of this bombing I
theorized that Kang might have wanted
Sylvie to bomb random parts of the
Sacred timeline so that she would feel
committed to the pot to follow through
on her plan to completely destroy it in
the finale but let's break down what we
see on Corona monitor ticker you can see
nowhere that's a separate Celestial head
where the guardians of the galaxies set
up shop in volume 3 and the holiday
special we learn from volume 3 it is
actually mobile there's no date listed
but maybe this altered win that
Celestial was beheaded next to that is
Barcelona Spain and underneath that
niflaheim that's one of the nine as
guardian Realms and where hella was
believed to be exiled so this could have
altered the outcome of hella invading
Asgard or made it happen sooner than
Dartford England that's birthplace of
Mick Jagger and Keith Richards so maybe
in this timeline they both went into
banking instead of becoming musicians
then on rensslayer's screen we see
August 3rd 1522 fungna Vietnam this
would have been raped before the
Europeans arrived in Vietnam so maybe
the reset charge altered the course of
colonial history then March 31st 1492
Lisbon Portugal this is the year of
Columbus's Atlantic Voyage so maybe that
was altered somehow April 23rd 2301
vormir warmir of course the resting
place of the Soul Stone seen in Infinity
war and endgame any change to vormir
would be potentially catastrophic
considering all the people have been
thrown off that cliff
so maybe this timeline change explains
why Red Skull used to be played by Hugo
weaving but is now played by Ross
Marquand then we see October 25th 1551
Thornton USA this might be a typo
because there is no Thornton in the
United States but there is a Thornton in
Colorado Colorado wasn't founded until
1876 Thornton uh wherever it is would be
named after the god Thor November 22nd
1999 Cookville USA that's in Tennessee
February 16 2004 Asgard so this will be
eight years before the events of the
first Thor of film maybe Thor and Odin
died in battle and Loki ascended to the
throne October 3rd 1390 Rome Italy
there's a lot of Wars going on in Italy
during that time a lot of coups and
arranged marriages for power August 13th
1984 sakarteo sakar of course the trash
plan for Ragnarok Teo is the name of
sakari's star system 1984 would have
been about 23 years before the events of
Thor Ragnarok so maybe this is during
the reign of the past Champion like one
of those four Champions on the grand
Masters Tower February 2nd 1808 barikara
Colombia so this would have been during
the French invasion of Spain which led
to an increase in loyalty to the king
maybe this changing the outcome of that
July 17 1708 purvue Finland at that time
Finland was a Battleground between
Russia and Sweden and the Great Northern
war corbu was sacked and burned by the
Russians so that could have been another
potential apocalyptic event that Sylvie
could have hid inside of December 27
1382 ego as in ego The Living Planet
Peter Quill's dad so maybe in this
altered timeline he made it with someone
else and successfully passed his genetic
godliness along to someone else like he
had always wanted October 13 1982 Titans
remember Titan that's a planet Thanos
grew up on the Runes of which he fought
the Avengers in in Infinity War 1982
would be about 30 years before his first
appearance in the MCU so maybe now the
planet was spared and Thanos never
embarked on his Stone Quest September
21st 1947 New York this would have been
right after the Yankees won the American
League pennant when the Red Sox were
eliminated and right before the Red Sox
then hired former Yankees manager Joe
McCarthy I just had to point out that
history for you March 1st 1984 Tokyo
this would be right at the end of a
massive snowfall event in that country
that led to 131 deaths so potentially
another apocalyptic event January 3rd 51
an A.D holla this is the earliest date
we see on any of the screens Paula is
the cree Homeworld seen in Captain
Marvel so they're like an ancient
civilization they reach Peak Evolution
years before Humanity did so maybe this
altar timeline was the start of their
conflict with the skrulls August 2nd
1909 Kingsport Tennessee couldn't find
anything important for that but Eric
Jepson the actor who played Minuteman
number four is from Kingsport so maybe
this is just the writers giving him a
shout out September 4th 1001 xandar
xandar is a home of the Nova Corps scene
in Guardians of the Galaxy this would be
right at the start of the cree Nova
Thousand-Year war November 23 2005
Beijing China this would have been a
couple days after George W bush attended
a church service and gunwashi Church in
Beijing 1903 Madrid Spain this one is
interesting because in Marvel comics on
this date Vlad Dracula created a Nexus
event and was arrested by the TVA in
Madrid so maybe this somehow ties into
the events of Blade and above the time
doors you can also see Portland in 2004
and then gottenheim landed the frost
Giants which is Loki's home realm okay
that's a lot of them the episode ends
Brent Slayer spring into action and
grabbing her staff ready to protect the
TVA and the timekeepers amidst his chaos
but on her helmet you can already see a
23 which of course is a nod to Avengers
number 23 ravana rensslayer's first
appearance when she was introduced as
romantic interest of Kang the Conqueror
now this detail features prominently in
episode 4 but this Kang clue was right
here in plain sight back in episode 2.
The glows and credits were updated on
the casting by credit to include photos
of Loki in his TVA variant jacket and a
photo of Sylvia in her Hood so our re
breakdown of episode 3 is coming next
and it's going to be interesting to
revisit lamentis one so I'm pretty sure
it's connected to the cree mining
colonies the annihilation War event that
could play a role in the Marvel's film
subscribe to all three channels of the
new rockstars Network and you can follow
me on Instagram Twitter at eavos follow
new rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for breakdowns of everything
Loki related thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign